so thanks for coming to this I hope
you've all watched the lecture in
advance we're do a Qui classroom here um
so I'm Eric kloer I'm a professor here
at MIT I run the teacher education
program um which is a program at MIT
that trains MIT undergrads to be Math
and Science teachers my research
primarily is in uh using video games and
simulations for math and science
learning uh but what I'm going to talk
about today are a series of four uh edex
mukes that we've been working on um and
the aspects I'm going to try to
emphasize are around the Project based
nature of these uh as well as the
community that we're trying to build in
these um and I'm uh since this is the
first session other than the keynote
I'll give you a little bit of context
for how this session will run I'm going
to try to be really brief about my talk
maybe about uh hopefully 15 minutes or
less uh talk about the work that we've
done but the idea here is to sort of
have a discussion around these issues so
discussions hopefully around issues
around uh using projects uh as the basis
of courses how you build community in
courses um and a lot of the social
interactions that we're trying to build
into our courses so I'm hoping that we
all have a dialogue around those things
I don't think I have any answers to any
of those questions um what I have are
experiments that we're trying um to
hopefully help Advance our knowledge in
this
space um so real quickly uh what I'm
going to do is uh I'm going to talk
about U computer supported Collaborative
Learning and what we have to learn from
that um in muks I'm going to talk about
how we've designed our own courses uh
really try to spend most of my time in
the next few minutes uh talking about
how we're trying to build community um
in the muks um specifically through peer
feedback sessions um and through our
forums uh a little bit about the
projects we're doing in the courses um
and that's pretty much it where I will
launch out into um hopefully building a
dialogue around this so originally when
I started out with this project as I
said my my background is in educational
technology um so I'm I'm I'm an educator
and so my original goal was as you can
see here trying to insert a little bit
of Education um both literally and figur
ly into edx um and now what's happened
is education actually is there although
um I do not have the responsibility for
for that I was not the first person was
actually dick Elmore at Harvard who had
the first course that was in there in
education but our two courses are now up
there two of our four 11126 and 11132 um
but our idea is in addition to really
getting courses about education into
edex um to do exactly what this
conference is doing here today and
tomorrow really thinking about how we
get really education and learning and
lessons of education and learning into
edex courses um and courses not even
specifically edex but more generally in
muks uh so we have uh four courses I
pointed out two of them
whoops
back builds take too long um we have
four courses that are launching two of
them are in the in the fall that I I
mentioned just now those are on the
design and development of educational
technology and the design and
development of games
we have two more launching in the spring
one on design development of educational
games and one on implementation and
evaluation of educational technology
these are what's known as an X Series uh
they they kind of all come together so
you can take all four courses and get
some sort of special certificate for
doing that but our goal is really to
help people think about the connections
between these the first two courses
definitely sort of lead into that
educational development of educational
games
course but along the things that we've
tried to do is sort of learn from not
just what's happening in other mood
courses but to think about what we know
about online learning um from other
kinds of experiences and specifically I
try to draw on um what's what's uh been
known as computer supported
Collaborative Learning and has a long
and Rich history going back uh 20 years
or so and this is Cecil and the later
knowledge Forum uh an online tool for
really supporting face-to-face
interactions in classes um for kids to
build knowledge about uh about uh
difficult topics together there's a
whole structure for how this is built
the technology itself um this is an
older Mac version but it doesn't look a
heck of a lot different than that right
now um the technology itself wasn't
super but the ideas the rich theory that
was supporting this about the way that
we get people to work with each other
online to really build knowledge
themselves in the constructivist way is
really
important um the basic premise of this
is that computer supported Collaborative
Learning uh locates learning in meaning
negotiation carried out in the social
world so this is not something that
happens in an individual's head but
something that happens in a social
context where we build understanding
about about complicated
ideas um so I've I've sort of defined a
series of factors that I've um that I've
talked about um the
locus the locus of the activity um the
locus of the of the kind of environment
the activity that goes on the structure
and the goals um this is for computer
supportive Collaborative Learning I'm
not going to going to go through the
other ones in detail other than the the
synthesis that I've made but the locus
of activity here is a centralized space
so they interact through a centralized
space for Collaborative Learning but it
supports face-to-face learning so
there's some face-to-face project that
people are doing that this environment
supports um the activity is online
activities building knowledge most of it
is discussion through forums but it's
very structured forums so you work in
groups small communities those forums
have sort of a structure the way that
people pose questions respond to
questions and ultimately build
understanding um the structure of these
are typically small classes the teachers
have structured where people within an
individual class interact with each
other occasionally sometimes people
interact across classes and the goals of
these are to build knowledge as a
community so it's not just building
knowledge within an individual's head
but building knowledge as a community
often around a particular project one
important thing that that the Cs
Community has made known and this is a a
publication from a few years ago on
computer supportive Collaborative
Learning and they say is simply not true
that the posting of content such as
slides text or videos makes for
compelling
instruction uh such content may be May
provide important resources for students
just as textbooks always have but they
can only be effective within a larger
motivational and interactive context and
that's really important to the notion of
what this kind of for is the idea is
that the Forum is not the is not the
place um where learning happens but the
learning happens as part of that that
experience um so this is what we're
building we call it edtechx that's what
our X Series is called um and we've
tried to combine some of those lessons
from from computer supported
Collaborative Learning as well as from
from X muks the muks that we mostly have
in edex and corsera and others as well
as the the connectivist mukes um that
really started this revolution as well
um and the things we try to do in ours
are our Locus is around a centralized
site we we're launching on edex um but
learning uh from a community um but you
learn from the community not just from
the from the a one-way
interaction the activities are Community
formation and networking around focused
content so the idea is that people will
actually have the the community itself
as not just a vehicle to learning but
the community itself is a is a goal um
the structure is weekly sylli typical
edex uh formats we have assignments I
mean each of the courses has a project
that it leads towards and our goal is to
sort of say the the certification that
you get for completing this course
obviously you can print off a
certificate yourself but the real
certification is that you've actually
have a project that you can show
somebody then at the end of the course
and our goal is then I participate and
then create that project the basic
components and I won't talk about all
these today are our video we have
situated video so there's very little
lecturing in these courses most of the
video um is interviews with other
experts in the field we've interviewed
um across all the courses something like
60 or 70 experts some of who are in the
room with us today uh so we it's
documentary style video we do interviews
we do sort of case
studies each of the projects each of the
courses has a project um social learning
through Community is a very important
aspect that's what I'll mostly talk
about today and we try to make the work
personally meaningful for them the other
thing I should mention is this is what
what's known as the DIY model here at
MIT the do-it-yourself model so we're
doing all the work within my lab itself
we don't have uh mitx is not um uh
dedicating Personnel to this they
dedicated resources and we're doing all
the work um within our lab itself and
it's a model for how you can try to do
some more of these these kinds of
courses without having a dedicated staff
um at at one centralized place so real
quickly on the video component um our
goals for doing the video in this way
was not something that lecturing is is
boring but really thinking about what
does the video represent um and our goal
was to represent that learning is
situated so each of these videos is
situated within a particular environment
within a particular context we know that
learning that goes on as experts is done
sort of within that context that
knowledge is Community Driven that's not
that I'm the single source of knowledge
within this space um but that I know
lots of people who are experts and I can
provide access to those and it's also to
see the way those experts apply the
knowledge themselves
um I won't show video but I'll show you
what some of the video looks like um
hopefully um these are some of the just
H uh these are some of the just stills
of some of the stuff that we show here
so there's interviews as you can see
sort of casual interviews on tacky
couches uh we have uh uh demonstrations
of people who are developing new
products and we have Studio tours that's
what's in the in this shot here this is
a a tour of a a game development Studio
talking about the way that teams work
together who are the different roles how
do they collaborate um and then other
experts that we sort of do in more
traditional um interview
style um the projects that we have for
each of these courses they're six weeks
long and they vary in terms of what the
projects are for the two courses on
games educational games and design
development of regular games um the
final project is some sort of game that
you're developing an educational game or
or or a just a an entertainment game uh
for the design development of
educational technology the final project
is a Kickstarter style pitch for new
educational technology but you have to
back that up with um with your theory
about the research that's going to
support this product uh Etc and the
implementation and evaluation of
educational technology is about an
implementation plan for some new
educational
technology the way that we develop those
projects is there's sort of uh parallel
tracks of assignments um there's some
assignments that come early on that are
uh that are much more structured in the
way that they're great or or evaluated
anyway um there's peer assessment that
goes on so you have some sort of
assignment that you have um you post
that assignment um you have peers that
that evaluate that assignment and get it
back to you um that's for the first few
weeks in the course um we pretty early
start though a more General and open
Community feedback uh structured
sessions where you're working towards
your final project pretty quickly um and
in those cases there's less structured
feedback instead you sort of post your
um your ideas your projects your videos
ultim your final projects within a forum
and then you get feedback um through the
community uh and I'll talk about how we
structure those different things um so
there's there's peer assessment there's
Community feedback and those sort of
merge towards the final projects at the
end um some of you may be have used peer
grading in your own courses or thinking
about using peer grading I'm interested
to talk about that and there's been some
controversy I'll say some people say
that peer grading simply can't work for
a number of reasons but there's been
sort of nice research that sort of has
has emphasized ways we can sort of
develop um uh rubrics and principles for
helping us structure peer grading so
that it can work effectively one of the
important things that we're doing is um
this is the typical grading structure
within an edex course um this is our
grade um so if you do anything you pass
and if you don't you fail um and so it's
pretty important for us that's one of
the the one of the ways of making peer
grading effective is to have low stakes
uh and our goal is really not to have
peer grading but peer assessment so we
want to focus on the feedback that that
and the learning that that people are
providing for each other not the grades
um we hopefully can structure and train
um people so that they can uh provide
that useful feedback um uh part of this
is is not just uh software engineering I
think this goes for a lot of the stuff
I'm going to talk about in terms of
community it's not just about software
engineering but it's about social
engineering how do we create communities
that allow this for this kind of
exchange uh and feedback in groups is
one of the things that we're trying to
emphasize so this is the way that that
forms typically look in in edex um or
course eras don't look very much
different than this nor to many of the
other forums that exist now so you have
one set of forums that exist there on
the side you have uh usually in the
first few weeks you have lots of people
posting and lots of different threads
very hard to sort through uh and uh and
then sort of uh participation falls off
pretty quickly in those forums but in a
lot of cases that's not essential to the
course those forums are there really to
support and for questions and in our
case where we really want to have the
forums as the basis for a lot of the
learning that goes on we want to make
sure that we can have the forms that
support that so we've um imported our
own set of forms that are going to be
attached to the course I won't go into
many of the technical details of how
we're doing this but if people have
questions on that I'm happy to to
entertain those questions and to have
that as a topic of discussion but it's
external forms that you can log into
through the same login that you do with
through your edex course so we have
things like um there's voting that you
can have you can sort things in
different ways um there's tags that you
can have here um there's lots of
different ways you can sort and find
things within these forums um that
provide additional levels of structure
that you don't normally find in uh in
these
forums um importantly we have along with
this an identity that goes with this so
for the most part your identity in in
muks is maybe the you can see somebody
who participates in a forum but you
can't really track them you don't really
develop any identity there certainly for
helping other people out uh so our our
goal here is to be able to provide sort
of a little bit of social networking
component where you can make friends
with this in this space you you can
track the number of posts that you have
um you can look at other people's
posting uh behaviors within this space
so our goal really is to create sort of
a community and I think identity is a
really important part of creating that
Community we've separated out um
discussion forums from question forums
so the discussion forums are for uh
posting things about um the the course
content U the question forums are if you
have a specific question that you need
answered sometimes it's a technical
question I don't know how something is
working I can't submit my assignment
does anybody have suggestions for how I
can upload a video um so for this we
have more of the kind of stack Overflow
style voting systems for questions where
you have uh you can sort things by views
you can vote on things you can vote on
the best answers for things people can
accept answers for questions that they
have it's a much more structured system
for allowing um question and
answers um so importantly for computer
supported Collaborative Learning to work
um it's about collaboration not just
sort of group participation so I won't
read this uh out loud but it's it's
about not not about sort of reacting
just simply in isolation to someone
else's post that goes online but
thinking about interactions that happen
as community and as groups and we need
to think about ways that we can foster
those discussions to happen not just as
one big Community but as smaller
communities some courses have gone to uh
posting uh you know dividing the class
up into alphabetical sections you know
so a through F go in this forum and G
through L go in another forum and that's
a nice way of sort of making a slightly
smaller community um what we've done is
uh introduced groups into our forums so
that you can have groups that are there
that allow for um uh that can be public
groups so people can open up a group and
anybody can join you can create private
groups where you have a small number of
people maybe from your profession from
your geographic area um from your school
that are together um and you can uh
participate in multiple groups you're
not isolated to one group necessarily
you can join multiple groups and our
goal here is to have people uh mostly be
posting their projects and their and to
get be getting feedback in these groups
so we'll also have a forum dedicated to
people getting into these groups because
that is an issue in and of itself and
there's been past failures in that
regard that um we don't want to we don't
want to Echo um but I think that
allowing people to sort of participate
in these smaller communities is is an
important way um to allow people to De
develop that identity and develop
relationships with other people uh so
our first course is is available online
now um it's launching in October uh this
is the one on design development of
educational technology two weeks later
we'll have one on games that launches as
well and that's open as well the last
thing I'll mention is um and this
relates to a little bit to what Susan
talked about this morning um we often
have difficult times you this Workshop
is a great way for us to kind of share
ideas about what's what we're doing what
works well what we're working on and
we've actually just launched and we had
some some flyers out front about this a
new website called education Express
it's a publishing platform uh that we're
trying to be able to create here that
allows people to share experiences um
that they're having in lots of different
forms of online and digital learning and
be able to do this in a much more rapid
rate than we can with through typical
online or or or print journals where uh
feedback Cycles often take years we're
hoping that we can keep these feedback
Cycles um on the order of weeks or
months and be able to create a much
better forum for people sharing these
ideas so with that I will say thanks and
the rest of the time we have for
discussion
so I I was asked to try to have the
microphones used in some productive way
so maybe
I'll I'm actually it's to say that
because in one of the videos for my
courses I do some
juggling um so what we'll do is it may
actually be useful to have I don't want
this dialogue to necessarily have to go
through me this is a this is a community
that we're hopefully creating here um
but I'll pass around these microphones
and hopefully we can pass around the
other microphones if if if you want to
response from me I'm happy to respond
but other people in the audience are
welcome to respond as well thank you
thanks for a really interesting a little
look at your work U I really appreciated
that um I had a question for you know
just absolutely anybody um I think that
there's kind of a chicken and egg
problem you know with some of these
Forum spaces right and it's it's really
you know it's a really complicated
problem to try to get people interacting
to try to build a community
like you know what you want it to look
like but obviously people come in and
they they take a look at the forums and
they're like okay what is this forum
Community is it a post a question get an
answer and I'm sure if your data looks
anything like our data right it's like
99.9% of students only look at the
forums they don't actually post right so
um I'm just interested in like you know
how anybody here approaches this kind of
problem you know um I'm also interested
in this idea of having an identity
online which you know I know a lot of
people like they want to know what other
people are who other people are but they
don't really want to disclosure is a big
problem online right um and there's some
benefit to if you're going to be grading
your peers to being able to do that in
an anonymous way on the other hand
there's also a really interesting
benefit to having like a one-on-one you
know relationship that continues between
you and and and the person that you're
grading or you're working on so you know
other strategies that other people have
used to approach that kind of issue with
forums I'd love to hear the these are
these are all great questions and I'll
throw it out there to everybody to
answer I will I'll I'll respond actually
on behalf of another colleague um
because when I some of this data has
come out on the participation rates in
the forums and I have one colleague uh
Dan McFarland who's at Stanford and um I
noticed that in the graphs that his his
graph is the outlier all the way on the
the high participation rate it something
like 80 or 90% of the people
participating in the forums multiple
times and I asked him how did you do
that and he just wrote back he said I
required
it so um so it's partially that but that
gets back to the sort of social
engineering aspects of this it's about
what do you express as a course what are
the values that we have as as a course
is the Forum is the community just sort
of an extra add-on that you want to say
that's it's okay if you participate or
is the community sort of a core value to
the system we um we and other we're
modeling with things other people have
done as well again our passing rate is
is uh you don't need to do very much to
sort of pass the course um but we do
have checklists each week which is an
assignment where you say did I
participate in the forums did I give
three people feedback um and it's on the
honor System for people obviously to do
that themselves and others have done
similar things but again it's a way of
sort of communicating to the community
what are the things that we're valuing
that you do within this course other
other thoughts yes yeah so I got the mic
so um so first I want to just say thanks
for this session because this is uh
something that was missing from the
keynote which is the inclusion of social
learning as a critical critical
component of what mukes are all about
and also for drawing on the history of
online learning research that has
existed for a long time so fantastic and
I just wondered if you could say a few
more things about the collaboration part
not just discussion and posting into
forums but but uh the collaboration
often creates that kind of glue that
lets peers share their expertise and
pool that expertise towards a kind of uh
product or submission assignment that
they have jointly developed and often
kind of creates a bond that will go well
beyond that initial assignment I just
wondered if you could say a few words
about how you've structured it and
whether you're noticing a bond that goes
beyond the initial assignment yeah so at
this point it's purely aspirational the
courses don't launch until until October
um uh but the audience that we've tried
to recruit are um are sort of diverse
audiences so for the design development
of educational technology course um uh
our goal was to sort of get people who
are coming from education who are more
interested in technology some people who
are more Engineers who are interested in
sort of moving into educational
technology as well as entrepreneurs who
sort of see educational technology as
the next big wave um and I think sort of
having this sort of more diverse
audience can allow people to sort of
create more interesting kinds of
projects you know if I'm coming from an
education side I may not have the
technical skills to really think about
how I could do this or think about the
business plan um so hopefully we're
going to try to get people to form
groups where you have sort of more
diverse sets of skills um where the
project that you develop then can
reflect those multiple different aspects
to it in the first few weeks when you're
doing those peer reviewed assignments we
expect those to be submitted
individually so those you do have
individual sort of accountability for uh
but as you move towards the final
project you can multiple people can
submit those same ones so they're just
being reviewed in the forums so when you
have these teams that are working
together they can submit one thing um
and all claim credit for that
equally so I wanted to comment on on
Katherine's question and also the
collaboration um in one of our sets of
classes the we did the sort of thing
that the gentleman was talking about
earlier about getting people incentives
to sit in the front we said if you
comment in this forum as the last person
you have to comment on everything that
was said before
you one you don't have to comment on
anybody else's stuff it worked a little
bit um but for collaboration I think you
really need something other than a text
based discussion form you need a Google
doc you need a sketch pad you need an ET
of sketch you need something like that
where people can literally go in and
write on the document and do block
diagrams and things like that I I think
I think you're right and there are the
the groups that the group
functionalities that we have built in
here do have some simple docs that you
can sort share with other people but not
as the highly interactive ways that you
have Google Docs and it's a it's a
question I think that we have as as a
community as to how much we want to sort
of build that into our courses those
kinds of tools versus what we sort of um
we can support maybe the teams being
created and we expect them to then use
those tools that already are freely
existing outside the courses themselves
and I I think it's an open question
there's reasons why we might want to
build them in uh certainly for Equity of
access across the world where maybe
people have certain sites that are
blocked um where for for research
purposes where we can capture that data
if that's actually happening within our
courses um but on the other hand it may
not make sense to build those all those
things if they exist already out there
so I just want to say one thing when you
when you do uh when you do have a
question just say who you are and where
you're from so Margo Seltzer from
Harvard so I want to follow up on sort
of this whole point about small group
formation and collaboration so we ran a
combo Muk Spock where um in order to
apply for the Spock you had to form a
group um so I we used a combination of
technologies that I'll talk about in a
minute and I I'd give it about a be
we're not happy with the Technologies we
actually need to improve so so we were
using pza for our online discussion
forum and then we sort of had a tailored
version of something called project
lever project lover however they
pronounce it um which is a platform that
was initially designed to help graduate
students find advisors and vice versa
and we had them tailor it so that you
could try to put together a
multi-disciplinary team that involved
you know a health care professional an
entrepreneur a finance guy Etc so a lot
of the same kinds of things you're
talking about and um with respect to
that first question about anonymity
versus identity on the Piaza Forum
people's identities could sort of be
whatever they wanted but in Project
lever since the whole goal was to
facilitate this diverse group
construction we encouraged people to
like upload their CV as part of the
process and so it gave the students sort
of two different ways to interact and
you were able to keep you sort of keep
your identity private until you find a
common interest and you sort of it's
it's kind of like a dating service right
you look interesting to me you can look
at my profile without knowing too much
about me are you interested and you know
should we meet in real life and and it
really does have a little bit of a
dating feel to it but that was sort of
how we balanced it out as I said we're
not happy we're going to go back and
revisit that but going back to your
question about collaboration these small
teams that formed to apply to the Spock
these guys produced business plans many
of whom are continuing now that the
course is over and are talking to us and
are actually going forth and actually
starting businesses so that's kind of
cool and kind of exciting and something
that you know could not have happened
because these teams have people from
different continents and it's kind of
cool that's great I I think I I I Echo
the need for the e-harmony for for work
groups online one of my former students
actually started one of those companies
and I'm working on it excellent keep us
posted but in some ways following up on
that actually is so what what is sort of
the group's opinion about oh sorry
Jackie from Smithsonian um what is the
group's opinion on um the role of sort
of a community manager if you will uh in
terms of uh facilitating dating or even
just saying so and so so and so
suggested this really great idea that
you might be interested in and clearly
more advanced tools make that much
easier to do in terms of Connecting
Threads of conversation and having
almost a little more of a Twitter esque
hopefully type of experience um but I'm
just curious to know what people's
experience in terms of the resources
that they've dedicated to that and what
the upsides been
I can actually start so um I'm an from
novoed and we have group formation on
the site um and we do a couple of things
to facilitate that one is with design
and of the course and the first
assignment and so it's not so much the
student profile who they are as a person
it's their identity as a Learner in the
course and so when people match up that
way you don't need so much the algorithm
you know what's they're more comfortable
doing it themselves
but as for Community manager one thing
that we're seeing that's work excuse me
working really well especially in our
entrepreneurship classes is having a
mentor so we're having mentors sign up
on the course as a mentor and then
students pick out mentors based on
criteria that's the dating part or
that's where that analogy is and then
the mentors really guide them and Coach
them through so this you way you can
really scale um and they work on these
same projects that then have real world
applications we've seen it in
mobile Health um you know Health apps
we've seen entrepreneurship apps we've
seen it in teachers we've got
Improvement science projects we' got a
ton of different
stuff hi M Lester from future learn
which is the UK based um M platform um
very interesting what you're doing um
and also all appreciate all the comments
coming in we I've I listen to this and
um it all resonates because actually the
way we've designed the platform form and
I think where you'll have some more
success with what you're trying to do is
we have a community so people do fill in
a profile there is that whole Twitter
style of communication where you can
follow people uh and and communicate
directly with them but what's really
what really makes our we don't really
call them forums because in each step
every video every disc every article
every piece has a disc its own
discussion area um that in itself
enables that water cool the convers that
people want to have when you consume
content and you want to create meaning
out of that content right there and then
that instant part where it's not
divorced you don't have a discussion
that's then on another area because that
psychological break is very important
but having it right there people engage
so our courses routinely have 50% of our
Learners commenting multiple times on
the courses that's not because our
universities are special at doing it
it's because that's what the platform
enables them to do and that's where the
mentorship and other things can come in
because actually what we have is other
students can follow by looking at
comments they can follow comments which
people who have made comments that they
found particularly useful it's the whole
idea of the zone of proximal development
you will learn most from people slightly
more advanced than you not over the
advanced than you are not under you but
you pick those and then filter those
comments so you can just see those
people and have a better dialogue and
it's all about facilitating that better
conversation which is what it should be
all about there's a lot of I think a lot
of great design principles in there um
and I know that in terms of discussion
and context I don't I haven't seen this
in any muks although it may exist but it
certainly exists on other place on the
internet are you know when you have an
article and you can sort of do
commenting anywhere you want in the
article and those comments sort of exist
within that space um and there's there's
I know tools already in development and
testing for doing similar things in
video where you can sort of comment at
particular places in the
video and I'll just jump in on the so
Paul Stacy with Creative Commons uh
about the community formation piece I
think it's a really great question it's
not enough clear to Simply plunk in a
technology and expect a community to
happen you actually have to structure it
to make it happen and a lot of success
around community building is also
involved putting in place let's call it
the mayor of the community whose role is
to bolster that kind of ground swell of
participation because often what you
find is that if someone will actually
help structure things to make activities
and and allow people to come forward
then then people will come forward so
somewhat like programming a radio
station you actually have to figure out
what you want what you want to happen
over the course of time and so I think
assigning someone even if it's a tutor
the role of a mayor or finding a mayor
from within the community itself can be
a really fantastic way to make it happen
I I'll just also Echo the last part of
what you said there in terms of um again
we're we're all of our stuff is
aspirational at this point but we've
talked to other folks who have used both
sort of dedicated staff from within
their own Labs or institutions as well
as these Community Tas who are people
who sort of rise up either quickly
really quickly or make contact in
advance of a course and people have had
success with that model as
well there and then here hi Sasha thury
Koka Community College I think it's
interesting all the emphasis on on the
activity in the social forums um I also
think it's interesting because we had a
a project where we looked at active
engagement using social media and
inactive engagement and we actually
found greater gains from people who were
lurkers as opposed to people who were
actively um commenting and posting on
the comments of other folks and much
like in this room there are those of us
who are speaking and there are a lot of
people hopefully who are not just uh
answering emails you know who are
participating but in a non um I think in
a non maybe commentar I don't know
commentary manner um so I wondered if
there was any research that you knew of
um or anyone in fact knew of on on the
correlation between um kind of that
ghosting that lurking in these social
spaces and actual achievement of the of
the outcomes and I understand that in in
your case the active engagement is part
part of the
goal do anybody
else comment over there on this on
this here you can
use right um we actually we didn't
research the lurkers but we noticed them
what we did research was that the
students that most actively engaged in
the forums had a higher retention and
and reached the the certificate I'm TI
to be from lien University we're working
with ker um and we've seen that over
four muks now so um there is that's one
of the reasons why we are investing into
Community Management because I'm
actually the community manager so we're
we're doing that I will add I mean so
you mentioned uh zone of proximal
development earlier and it's something
that people have done research on and in
forums in the past I know colleagues who
have done this in the in forums that
surround the use of games um and for
people who are new to the community they
actually don't feel ready to necessarily
participate right away so if you're in a
community where you feel like there are
already experts if you're a novice you
don't feel ready that you can like
asking your questions going to look
really dumb um so so you do often lurk
first but that is a that lurking in that
way is being sort of in that zone of
proximal development because you're sort
of in this um some sort of legitimate
particip peripheral participation you're
actively reading the reading the forums
maybe you're sort of finding which are
the most important forums figure out who
are the people who are good in those uh
figure out the kinds of questions the
way people pose questions in that space
so there ways of being readers in that
space and and and participating
legitimate ways before you actually
become a poster so I think that it is
it's a behavior I think that's hard to
capture because the the rest of it you
can see that what people read and maybe
how often they read but you can't really
know what sort of is going on in their
head as they read those
things
you have the you have the mic so you get
you get next oh is okay hi I'm chinai
from Stanford University and I I think
speaking a little bit to what you said
uh uh I think a good way uh a good place
to look at the sort of community
building is an offline communities if
you look at say things like Jane Jacobs
and she talks about familiar strangers
there's a lot of familiar strangers on
muks right you see these people on
forums and you know them kind of but not
really right and I think one design
level that we have here is that familiar
strangers can become more uh
collaboratives or you know uh people who
are more actively engaged with you uh I
so I have this one research project it's
called talk about and the way uh we do
this is we we just have small group
video discussions and you're paired up
randomly with someone from anywhere in
the world right so that is more like
chatr than it is dating in some sense
but uh what you have seen is that at the
end of these discuss discussions a lot
of times people actually go out of the
way and then share disc uh their uh
personal information like LinkedIn
profiles and so forth so I think there
is a ramp up from going from a familiar
stranger to a collaborator and we should
be you know probably leveraging that a
lot more
yeah did we lose one of our
mics is there a mic out there somewhere
still I think they're doing a follow on
I okay I have a follow and a new
um followup is that I who are you oh
sorry I'm Margaret chadel from Stony
Brook University and I did a corsera moo
and I used it to flip my classroom and
the second time that I did it I noticed
that my in-person students weren't using
the forums very much so the second time
I did it I required them to participate
in the forums and then they had to
journal about how they helped someone
and I actually noticed that the forums
came alive because I had 80 students in
person having to sort of seed that
experience um and my other question is
for the courses that you are teaching
that sequence I'm looking on at X you're
it's 6 weeks long but the second one
starts two weeks after the first so
they're overlapping and I'm just
wondering why and that's totally
unrelated um it's it's a question of how
we pull off four in one year um and so
we decided that we would have to overlap
them in order to be able to do that um
it's a it's a design constraint
unfortunately not not an affordance as
far as I'm concerned Al if some people
take the
same hi I'm Louisa I work with Eric on
these mukes um if some people are taking
both of the courses there's definitely
um a lot of ways that each course will
inform their work in the other course so
like if they're designing games and they
want to um do a games project as part of
the first course they'll have the tools
and more ability to do that so there is
there is some benefit for people that
are taking both which hopefully will be
a lot of people since it's in a series
so so that's one
aspect um so I'm Joseph Williams I'm at
Stanford now but I'm moving to Harvard X
in September and so one thing I was
curious to hear your thoughts and
everyone else's is thinking about what
the role of modularity or modularizing
these efforts might be um because some
tensions that seem to have been brought
up or one is that iterative revision
that you're doing in your course and
training people to do but then also how
you bring communities around something
and so if we were to think of how do you
take a whole Muk and instead of thinking
of the C level can we think almost more
like mlet like modules or decomposing it
that might make it easier to revise them
and it's also means that you could take
one course instead of one Community you
could have many different communities
around pieces or you could bring
together like Susan singer mentioned
this morning researchers and
practitioners um so I'm curious to hear
people's thoughts P at Stanford we've
sort of had a a discussion group about
like a mlet group where we think about
different aspects of how mlet can let us
iteratively revise collaborate and medic
experiments so I'd be really curious to
other people's thoughts I know a lot of
people have been thinking about modules
as well I I think from my perspective
with there's so you have a comment on
that um from my perspective uh with
respect to community um it's it would be
important in those cases to think about
ways that you have both uh identities
and groups that can persist across those
Muk lits if if you call them that um
because you know that to develop
Community takes a while six weeks even
in of itself is probably is on the short
side of that and maybe for an intense
experience it works but if it's down to
two or three weeks it's probably too
short but if you have ways of sort of
interconnecting those I mean the
modularization sort of goes along with
the ways that you connect these so if
you have identity if you have groups
that can persist across those um some
sort of U meta infrastructure uh that
allows you to do that that that can
facilitate some of those things
happening even within that kind of
context you excited to hear that topic
um Susan Huggins Kaplan University in
Fort Lauderdale we recently launched
what's called open college at KU which
is a new initiative to try to bring some
open learning resources to our students
at in a that currently exist in a more
traditional environment um and one of
the things that we did do is
modularize courses several reasons first
of all to group them into smaller
segments because Learners often are
gravitated toward learning that takes
less time they learn just what they need
when they need it um and we also created
assessments that matched the modular
modularized learning so if a learner
comes to us and you know say they've
been a manager for 15 years and they've
got all this managerial knowledge except
in this one area they can actually come
to our uh open course and learn just
that one area so that's another reason
we did the modularization is so that
Learners can learn what they want to
learn not take a whole course to try to
dig out what it is they need and and so
I think actually building on that uh and
also on a comment that that Susan said
about um we're doing the wrong kind of
flipping um it's about sort of putting
problems first and then sort of
materials second um and you know if if
those mlet could really be sort of
really just heavily content based but
you could imagine a surrounding project
that you want to do so now I want to
build a solar car is one you know those
kinds of things that people talk about
build a solar car what what are the what
are the component things I'm going to
need to learn from that what are the
mlits that I need to take in order for
me to be able to build that project and
maybe there's a separate sort of
community that's about this is a Project
based thing for you to build solar cars
and we're going to have discussions here
and you can go here's the things that
can help support you so you can sort of
think about other ways and kinds of
structures that can help um support
those those smaller modules and a at a
face- to-face university those things
might exist
locally microphone up there so
I'll um we've been talking talking about
forming communities in a online World um
I wanted to comment on an experience I
had uh on my residential course in which
uh for the last few years I've struggled
to get participation and discussion
forums and last year I discovered that
um when I required it of course they
posted and that was part of the grade
and so on but I discovered they had a
very active discussion forum in Facebook
outside of my view and so I was
wondering if you had any thoughts about
uh you know for me as a teacher I wanted
to see what's going on there uh for
there as the students they didn't want
me there uh so I was wondering how much
of the benefit you see in the learning
of the students
occurs uh through community that they
may be forming in particular in
residential courses are also forming
community in personto person
interactions do anybody have have
thoughts on that you it builds into the
point that or the thing comment that I
wanted to make um Jamie Laro Bunker Hill
Community College um I I've used a lot
of the research that um Jane mcgonagal
did on game game research and
incorporating that in education and I
have found a lot of success in creating
communities using game style tactics you
know Point earning points and having a
an avatar or some kind of um profile or
whatever um and also having small tasks
that students can complete and and get
kind of instant feedback on and that's
been very successful both in online and
iners formats I've used a we have a
social engineering game in an in an
ethical hacking course that we have
where students earn points for
completing social engineering tasks um
and also in a help desk techniques
course where students earn points for
completing um coming up with a help desk
scenario in which they're having a
problem they're the person calling in to
help desk and the other students have to
respond to that problem um and vice
versa and it also has cultivated a lot
of this peer-to-peer
learning mainly I've done this because
in community colleges we don't have Tas
we don't have assistance we don't have a
lot of help and so I need the students
to help each other I need them to
collaborate so that they can get the
most out of the course possible so um so
I've tried to take the Facebook model of
you know kind of the friendly and and
incorporated into the course in some way
shape or form through kind of game
social media tactics I I'll add a couple
things on the on the Facebook point it's
something we've wrestled with how much
do we want to Mo Facebook groups pop up
around a lot of online courses um and
the question is why um and so there's
different things around well maybe they
pop up because that's where people are
and so they just put things there so no
matter what I would do um they would
also sort of pop up there and that that
may be the case but it maybe that
certain features in the styles of
interaction um and other things like
that that that's that are not present in
the more very highly structured forums
that we see typically um in online
courses don't sort of facilitate the
same kind of communication that they're
more familiar with and so we can figure
out ways to sort of get more of that
happening within the course and I think
there are good reasons for trying to do
that one is to make sure that people
aren't left out for different sort of
access reasons the other is obviously
for our own research that we can sort of
improve things if we know what people
are talking about um and I will also say
that um similar I think to what to what
you've seen I've used forums for my
face-to-face courses for many years now
where students do some activity outside
of class that sort of then continues on
in class and they then continue to use
those forms to support each other in
cases where I don't require it even
outside of
class I think over here so my name is
Ursula woles and um I have a little
startup and in order to uh finance my
mortgage is probably the best way to put
it um I've been an itinerant faculty
member I was at the College of New
Jersey for 20 years spent a year at Olan
College which is kind of the oppos
opposite of a online institution and
then at a couple of state colleges in
New Jersey um and I've been I've run
online courses I've designed online
courses I've used them in i' I've run
the gamut it's been a fun couple of four
or five years but I wanted to follow up
on on the Facebook model I've actually
done that where I've created a forum
that's entirely for my students and this
was recommended to me for some people
who do um game design and that is
essential for for them to have a private
place where I can't get in there and
understand who's doing what and how
they're doing it um and then I also
wanted to follow up on the uh the idea
of how do you motivate them into a
collaborative space I've done this with
everything from middle schoolers to
graduate students um I put them on
Google Drive and I open up um the draw
facility and I say draw me a mural and
after they get past erasing each other's
stuff and changing the colors and all of
that um they actually give me a really
nice expression and you get to see a lot
about their personalities and they get
to see the personalities of each other
it turns out for me it's worked better
in a in a face to-face class than when
I've done it in a in a distance distant
environment and I asked my distant class
about this and they told me it's because
they could giggle with each other next
to each other and one of them actually
did this pretty little Design This was
in a technology course of how she would
facilitate that kind of knowing the
person who was doing the drawing and all
of that so there's something to be said
for
the that the community can happen but
getting some kinesthetic information
about that person next to you seems to
be really
important
good up
there I'm actually curious about um is
it okay or yeah the microphone's got to
make its way over to the other side so
okay you go I was going to I was going
to switch it a little bit unless does
somebody do you have a followup over
there because I was interested in
exploring like the Project based
components of some of this we've talked
a lot about the social and connectivist
kind of uh pedagogy within this so is
that okay or do you have a do you have
something on top of the Facebook because
I don't want to um um well not so much
Facebook but sort of this notion of a
community so Rob blue at Harvard um so
coming back to that issue of what
modularization might mean but also the
issue that's um increasingly muks and
other online courses have extremely long
duration now so that folks can come in
at very different times one might argue
that that flies in the face of a stable
community but I wonder if this notion of
stability is perhaps too constrained too
fixed and can we think of sort of a
dynamically stable community where folks
come in and folks leave but that at at
really any given moment there is a
functional community that is learning
effectively but that would really free
us of the need to really Define the
duration or even Define the content that
they're tackling has anyone tried to
create such a dynamically stable
community that moves throughout time but
the membership changes over time
that's yeah I mean that does happen
right the comment in case you couldn't
hear the on online games that happens
right so you have you have some activity
you have people that come and go from
that activity um even within that
activity there are groups that sort of
evolve and change and then certainly the
community that exists outside of it uh
the forums that exist outside of that
those also have um have that sort of
dynamic um that Dynamic space it's a
question of how the those are usually
the ones that are successful are very
large so there's a something about scale
there where if you um two things I think
that I can think of from playing those
games one is that you have scale so you
have you can have lots of people coming
and going you can still have a large
number of people who are there for a
while and the other is to sort of have
something that you can continue to do in
that space so some of uh and there are
many things that people do in online
games some of is they take a new
character and they bring it all the way
back up again and so it's taking a new
trajectory through the same space so how
do we do that with courses they are sort
of providing new and ongoing challenges
so the game itself changes over time so
there's new and ongoing challenges
within that space um and there's um and
there's also mentorship that goes on so
like you you act so there's the role
that you play Within those games that
the game tells you you play but the what
you do in that space as a human being um
does change so I might go from a Learner
in that space to s a more Mentor in that
space where I'm helping other people do
that so I I some people helped me
through that online game now I'm helping
my kids through that online game so
there how do you sort of change uh ways
that allow people to participate in in
different kinds of ways within that
space here do we have course examples
online that do that are there any so so
the the only things I can think of so
some of the connectivist mukes um were
more persistent because they were highly
individual in terms of what people were
doing and the content itself could grow
because people could keep adding things
to those so the fact that the courses
themselves were Dynamic I think I don't
know what the what the stats are but
they I think they lasted a fair bit
longer than our typical mukes do here um
I will say one really trivial thing that
we that we are planning on doing for
ours I'm not sure whether we're actually
going to do this um it's not getting
nearly all the way to where you're
describing which I think is exactly what
we would like to do
um but uh for each of the forums where
you're that are Project based um we're
thinking about doing synchronous and
asynchronous forums so the synchronous
are for people who are doing it the week
that the syllabus says that you're
supposed to do it and the asynchronous
is for people who lag some number of
weeks and so we'll keep the course open
for a little bit longer allowing people
who lag some number of weeks to sort of
exist within that space and be able to
do that so it provides some flexibility
not nearly as much as you and it doesn't
really have the advantages because I
think what you get at an idea like yours
is you get a community that can sort of
really be functional really and the
course material is just one part of that
function I just another follow on that
which was um which was just to look
at all right thank you um I just had
another example which is maybe to look
at you know learning coding right online
on all those like huge like programming
you know kind of communities which um
you know is is kind of like both
overlaps with University you know muks
and and also is like a whole world of
its own and I think they've done some
incredibly successful you know
structures of courses online for that
sort of
thing I can just answer the question
vivec well from corsera and University
of Toronto there was a um introduction
to programming course that the
University of Toronto left open after
the session ended and that kind of
community continued to exist and people
would be answering there were there was
basically a small group of what I would
describe as super users who stuck around
and would answer questions for people
who would be coming in and doing the
problems in the course so it is I think
possible to create those kinds of
communities where there was one do there
was a member of the a member of the
community emerged um who was clearly in
industry and wasn't an academic and
everybody basically followed his course
notes in order to survive the first
version of this this move and and it was
a programming one um what was
interesting is that I got a forign
notice about about 4 months later where
are you we need you in the second course
and so apparently there was a community
that continued on and and the Dynamics
of of the community shifted um I I
grabbed the microphone because I wanted
to follow up on a point you made we
think about that older person being the
mentor um but in my personal life I have
a 21-year-old son and a 14-year-old
daughter and they are both Pokemon
Fanatics and I was floored at the inter
table two nights ago I hadn't seen my
kids in a couple of days and they were
talking about how the younger one has
grown up in the online Pokemon Community
where you can trade Pokemon rather than
capture them in the wild I know this is
all I can't wrap my head around this
okay it's it's all I know okay so and
but it turns out that she is far more
effective at trading than her older
brother who grew up in the in the single
user community and has no trading
expertise and so she was teaching him
how to trade and so their ex it's not
that you know he's the older wiser but
rather that's what I'm seeing in in the
communities that are happening um in my
classes as well it's all anecdotal but
this is a case in point that I think
it's happening whether we can capture it
in a formal research perspective or not
is difficult but you have to step back
from it and understand that everybody
can teach everybody
else well so so sort of a follow-up
comment the reason why I I posed this in
part is is because as we think about how
the courses evolve in response to
research in response to what instructors
are doing in response to what
educational researchers are discovering
if one creates an ongoing sort of
dynamically stable community to what
degree can we capture what the Learners
are creating and discovering to help the
course evolve even
further and actually that that was
somewhat the comment I was going to make
on Rob's comment Beth from etex um we're
really interested in sort of the dynamic
that gets created between in in a self
um study course one that isn't proctored
or run in an exact period of time with a
set of outcomes that need to be you know
sort of delivered on a schedule and how
people will use or capitalize on that
experience differently than how they
would do it in a more traditional moo
where you have a it's running at a
certain time and place we haven't I
won't pretend that we've figured that
magic formula out yet but it sounds very
much like what Rob is referring to which
is that can you get something something
that gets to a sustainability model and
just can keep going but also is tied to
outcomes actually getting to achievable
Milestones over time and not just a
community because we can make
communities all over the place um but
aren't necessarily tied to uh goals or
uh milestones in time where you can say
hey I I've got that little marker i'
I've earned that badge I've earned that
certificate I've earned that credential
and now that shows that I've I've
achieved something and I could use it to
to go someplace else with my with my
knowled so that's what it triggers for
me your comment was about the difference
between those kinds of learning
experiences and how to set them up
successfully it might also relate back
to the to the mlet comment from earlier
um about things that sort of projects
that might surround this and so the
project themselves the mlet May sort of
be you kind of use them as you need to
use them come and go from them and
different projects could persist for
different amounts of time depending on
the sort of scale of the problem I think
the the the interesting thing about the
sort of the the coding ones sort of
persisting sort of I wonder if there's
something about the nature of the of the
the content itself that sort of Might
promote um the applied nature of that
problem um being just used to solve
practical problems might be something
that um might lead more to certain kinds
of uh courses persisting than others no
I just wanted to say because you know
it's so content specific right I mean
there there are certain topics Project
based topics that people where people
learn skills individually where that
kind of setup works really well but if
you're having people come together over
four weeks to come up with something and
you need the pressure of time right to
create something in different skill sets
and experiences then having it open for
forever doesn't work so I think we
should you know we talk about these
Technologies and what we should do but
we should really think too how it works
sensitively with
content if I might actually uh thank you
by the way for the uh long awaited segue
into projects
um like do I hand this off I don't want
to stop the conversation but thank you
for that um Nathan Benjamin from
extension engine one of the things
that's really interesting to me about
Project based learning and really hard
um is so to your point earlier about all
learning needs to be personally
meaningful and as Dr singer said all
learning occurs in an interaction
between prior knowledge and new
knowledge which means all learning is
subjective anytime you scale the ability
to kind of subjectively instruct goes
from an apprenticeship model to a
lecture model which is 500 to1 to now
we're talking 20,000 50,000 100,000 to
one how do you create and I'm curious
how you created a story that you felt
was going to be personally meaningful
and engaging for your learners and then
second of all at a more kind of micro
level um the actual projects that they
were engaging in how did you create
authentic interactions for them to for
them to perform the projects and to mark
from future learns point I'm curious if
you used X blocks to like port in pieces
of like a real Kickstarter task into
like via an API or something so that
they were performing authentic tasks in
Kickstarter but also sort of
disassembled and and situated so so for
our two games courses um what we decided
we needed to do was develop our own
online game development tool that didn't
require a lot of programming knowledge
prior um so that was been a significant
investment on our part and and my TX is
part in sort of developing that tool so
we wanted to give people a real tool for
making real games online but didn't
require necessarily a lot of background
in terms of how to make games uh
certainly the the programming aspect so
that was that was something we did have
to build and it is built in so that you
can log in and you can share projects
all within our edex course so that that
was the and that's the culminating
project for those two courses on games
uh for the kickstarter one our idea
there was to sort of try to try to make
it authentic is we're give you can use
whatever you would like um and it's sort
of up to you to decide whether it's a
video whether it's a you know a series
of images that you have and sort of a
static web page it's up to you sort of
how you want to share that ultimate
product that you have we can give them
some we're going to give them some
templates in terms of what that pitch
might look like um and for different
kinds of pitches it might be different
because we actually allowing them to
pitch like a Kickstarter more of like a
crowdfunding thing where you might be
sort of uh uh your audience is is your
funders um but we're also going to allow
for more of a sort of a VC style pitch
where your where your pitch is to
someone who might be funding you instead
do they do they Define what the producte
product is themselves they Define what
the core product is themselves yes so
they they get to decide what the product
is it has to be some educational
technology um they have certain criteria
it has to have a research basis has to
have a theoretical basis they have to
have a way of assessing it
yes but but what it is that they're
doing is totally up to them and I do I
can't remember who said this before but
the idea I think it was uh the having a
persistence beyond the course our hope
is that it's one of our metrics is do
some of these ideas go live without
outside of the course do some of these
ideas um become real real Kickstarter
pitches to some of these games become
something that someone develops into
something later
on now back
to I realize it's lunchtime uh Jackie
Hood from open doors group I used to
teach at Foothill deanza Community
College District and in my six classes
on project management and help and
customer support
first I reminded everybody that our
economy is 80% services not objects so
services are more important to create
than objects um and so each team had to
support one of the Technologies we used
the learning management system Excel
PowerPoint or the online meeting tool
and then the teams also created
educational games but they didn't have
to be video games card games board games
parlor games video games we only had one
team 18yar olds who committed who did a
video game um my class ranged from 18
year olds to mid to late career people
and they um it was interesting that the
lurkers changed positions in the class
the younger students were in the back
not not up in the front running things
online It reversed to some extent a lot
of the people were less comfortable with
technology and I made them when the
video game was demonstrated get out
there and play with their thumbs and
they didn't want to do it you know they
they didn't know how to type with their
thumbs so it took some learning and and
um so I think the the lurker thing and a
lot of teachers notice this that
students who sit in the back and never
say anything in class will say things
online that they wouldn't do in class
and then the last one was about the
long-term
communities um there's a 5,000 member
International Community of project
managers helping each other get project
management certification and many of
them stay in after they get the CER
certification and help the others and
they all learn and especially they learn
from the people who failed the test why
they failed so on one last one on udem
me if you've watched all their on demand
courses there's a real pressure on udemy
now to have real discussion forums and
these classes go on for years and years
tens of thousands of students taking the
same class and we believe we'll get that
constant persistance of the community if
they really make real Forums on you to
me
great so now now it is lunch time um I'm
happy to stick around for a minute if
anybody else wants to talk to me um but
you are you're all free to go thank you
for the great discussion this was a
really good
session